- A young adult presents to the office
with body aches, fatigue, and joint pain.
What happened next may surprise you.
Let's get started.
Before I walk in to see the patient,
I actually do a chart review
to see if the patient
has been seen before,
what the vitals are,
what information has been shared
with my medical assistant.
And I find out that the patient
has actually seen several other doctors
over the last few weeks
for the same issue,
and hasn't gotten a satisfactory answer,
meaning a diagnosis or
treatment to solve the issue.
In looking through the notes,
I saw that the patient
was initially diagnosed
with arthritis,
that they attributed to the
patient being overweight.
His BMI, I think, put
them into the category
of morbid obesity.
While that can cause osteoarthritis,
he seemed to be a little bit too young
for that to start happening.
I walk in to see the patient,
I introduced myself.
One of the first questions is
what has been the diagnosis thus far?
What have all the doctors told you?
You went to see a doctor first
who diagnosed a patient with arthritis
related to his weight.
The treatment for that was
some over-the-counter medications,
which I thought was a
rather incomplete treatment,
even if that was the correct diagnosis.
Then patient said when they went home
and tried the over-the-counter options,
the pain did not get better at all.
In fact, it got worse
and then a rash appeared.
So the patient over the weekend
went to an urgent care facility
where they gave the patient a cream.
When I investigated what the cream was,
it happens to be a topical steroid
and the rashes did go away with the cream.
However, over the period of about 10 days,
the pain in the joints, in the muscles,
specifically, the knees, the elbows
started to return for the patient.
So he came back to that
same doctor and said,
"Hey, why am I not getting
better with the treatment,
what's going on?"
And the doctor made some other evaluations
and ended up sending
the patient for x-rays
to see if there was anything going on
from the imaging side of things.
And again, reiterated to the
patient that the suspicion was,
all the symptoms were coming from
the fact that the patient was overweight.
Clearly that wasn't the issue.
If you look at the course
of illness for this patient,
the fact that it was getting worse,
there's not only joint pain,
but there's also body aches.
There's also fatigue setting in,
rashes starting to happen.
These are multiple systems being involved
and that tells me something
systemic is going on.
I decided to ask the patient,
if he sent a message to any
of his friends of the rashes,
typically we do that, right?
We're like, "Oh my God, what is this?"
And we take a picture with our iPhones.
And to my luck, he did,
he took a picture of the rash
early on when it started.
And it looked like an erythematous,
meaning very red rash of the skin.
He only had a picture of one of them,
but he said, all of them
looked quite similar.
Now this is unique
because the fact that
it's not happening again
in one area
tells me that it's not an isolated
or localized reaction to something.
If I have a reaction
right where my watch is
that tells me something
is going on in this area,
either there's a contact dermatitis
where I'm allergic to one of
the components of the watch,
maybe a fungal infection from
trapping of the moisture.
So the localized nature of the
rash would tell me something.
But when we have a rash,
that's happening all across the body,
that means something's
happening internally.
Whether it's in the blood,
in the lymphatic system,
I need to think further.
So I started putting
pieces together and I said,
"Wait, you have fatigue, joint
pain, body aches, a rash.
Does this patient have Lyme disease?
So I asked the patient,
does he spend a lot of times
outdoors, hiking, gardening?
And he said, "No, absolutely not.
I'm kind of a home body.
I like to stay home.
I don't really go outside much."
And I'm like,
"Do you have a dog?"
And he's like, "Yeah, I love my dog.
I sleep with my dog."
I'm like, "Has your dog ever had a tick?"
I see his eyes opened wide.
And he says, "Yes, my dog,
I actually pulled a tick off of him
not that long ago."
The way that we get exposed to ticks
is not only through being
outdoors and in tall grass,
but through carriers or vectors.
Like, Bear can literally run
into a big forest and area,
get a bunch of ticks on his fur.
And him being brown, me not see it,
climbs into my bed,
leaves one of the ticks next to me.
And they could easily start
feeding and cause an infection.
Every other provider he seen thus far
wrote them off as just an
allergy, needing some medications,
it's all due to his weight.
Weight is a problem for
a lot of my patients.
A lot of my patients do suffer
with their quality of life
because they fall into the
category of morbid obesity.
But it's also not right to
blame everything that's going on
without doing a proper
history and physical.
Like, that gets lost right then and there.
So at this point we make a decision
that I think what's going on
is that the patient had
an erythema migrans rash.
But what's unique is
erythema migrans sometimes
appears with multiple lesions
throughout the body.
And sometimes they're all completely red,
and they don't all look like
the prototypical bullseye rash
that we study in our textbooks.
But then I started having to think
the patient actually has early
disseminated Lyme disease.
Why?
Because he's starting to have joint pain,
migratory arthritis,
body aches,
which is myalgias,
basically pain in the muscles
that means the inflammation is spreading.
And unless we catch these
and act appropriately,
it could lead to further Lyme, late Lyme,
which is very problematic
because then it could spread to your heart
causing things like arrhythmias,
AV blocks,
neurologic complications.
We had to act quickly.
We drew blood then in there
to do two tests,
one the ELISA test
to make the initial
diagnosis of Lyme disease,
and then a Western blot
to do the confirmation test for it.
And then right away prescribed
a course of Doxycycline,
which is an antibiotic that we like to use
for the treatment of Lyme.
Patient follows up two weeks later,
what do we find out?
A, his Lyme tests, both positive,
b, he feels a hundred times better.
Zero fatigue,
zero joint pain, zero muscle aches.
He's completely cured.
Had he progress to late
stage Lyme disease,
and had neurologic or
cardiac complications?
He may have needed a hospital
stay for IV antibiotics.
He could have lost his life
as a result of a cardiac arrhythmia.
If you happen to be a patient
and you feel your provider is
overly focused on your weight,
and you feel like you're
not getting good care
because of that,
you have two options:
Option one,
be direct point out to your provider
that you feel like there's an
overemphasis on your weight.
And while you know it is an
important factor in your health,
it's not the sole
determinant of your health.
And you'd like to have a
further discussion on that.
If they're not receptive,
move to option two,
or if you don't even wanna
have that conversation,
that's your choice to move to option two,
which is seek a second opinion.
That is your right as a patient,
and insurance cannot deny you
for seeking a second opinion
because medicine is as much
art as it is a science.
The relationship between
a provider and a patient
has to be strong
in order for a proper
health outcomes to occur.
(ominous music)
I wanna stress this super strongly.
Be careful with certain health providers
who make the diagnosis of a condition,
which is not really a correct condition
of chronic Lyme disease.
They say that you need to
do all sorts of treatments
like chelation therapies,
extremely long courses of antibiotics
that have no real evidence for them.
And they blame a lot of
my patient's symptoms
on this chronic Lyme disease,
when in reality,
that's not what's going on.
If someone's pushing on you,
expensive lengthy complex treatments,
seek a second opinion
either with another primary care doctor
or even an infectious disease specialist,
because there's a lot,
a lot of fraud and malpractice
that happens in this area.
And I've seen my patients truly suffer.
That's just one of my patients' stories,
but click here to check
out my bizarre life
as an attending doctor as
always stay happy and healthy.
Click here to check that out.
(upbeat music)